spring near Rappaport's it's a great job
covering the NFL for the NFL Network he
joins us here on the show let's start
Miami Ian what's what do we know at this
point about Ryan Tannehill
injury and the severity of it well
honestly we don't know much and that's
kind of where the Dolphins are right now
it's you know a lot of different reports
and some from us and some from others
and seems to be a lot of different
options right now for the Miami Dolphins
and they include waiting and resting and
seeing if he's okay
him being okay you know he's going for
the second opinion and maybe another
opinion after that try to figure out
what's actually wrong with his knee
resting is an option and rehabbing for
several weeks perhaps something that
would cause him to miss the start of the
season that's an option as is full
reconstructive ACL surgery the kind that
was you know obviously milestone last
time and that's a wide range of options
that's basically all of them and you
know the reality is the Dolphins just
don't know right now if Daniel is
significantly injured do you think they
look outside the organization for help I
think they probably will you know let's
say this is a scenario where we're
talking you know if he is out for half
the season or the whole season or
something like that you know obviously
Jay caller is a name to watch mainly
because of his history without a case
you know Cutler had his best year in
Chicago with case they are I would say
friendly or close
certainly they talk away from the field
and all that and have remained at
contact you know so that would be a name
to watch and ink on Kaepernick is you
know probably a lesser name to watch but
but not someone to rule out and the
reason I say that is because you know
money is a factor I mean Jay color is a
starting quarterback in the NFL or at
least you know was when he was playing
and does he want to be paid like that
again if he does of the Miami Dolphins
ready to write a thirteen million dollar
check that is a very legitimate question
that I don't know the answer to why do
you think the Colin Kaepernick
has not done a sit-down interview with
somebody to kind of fill the vacuum a
little bit with all this speculation
that's out there you know that's a good
question you know I'm sort of among the
people who think he should but that's
not specific to him I think everyone
should you know I always I always sort
of favor people being out and open and
discussing where they are in the various
issues if there's something to address
you know now it's kind of got to a point
where you know maybe Kaepernick is not
going to do it because everyone's asking
for it and you know what does you really
have to explain but you know I don't
know would it help honestly I probably
not but I'd be interested in listening I
mean I don't would help either but it
seems like there's so much reporting out
there or speculation
you know I saw wasn't charlie casually
was the speculating that does he want to
play anymore I mean people have said
that for months now a whole kneeling
thing I mean it just seems like there's
a lot of information he could clear up
in one short interview if that was it
yeah yeah but the kneeling thing was you
know 12 months ago he's done many many
many interviews since one so what would
an interview right now prove or show you
know he has to so if he says the words
yes I'd love to play football then you
know all the sudden people would sign
him like I'd be interested in listening
the interview don't get me wrong but you
know this is not a situation where a
player needs to be rehabilitated or you
know when his win Society back I mean
what did he do wrong what is he trying
to explain I mean he's explained the the
anthem protest which I don't agree with
but I certainly agree he has a right to
do it as a citizen so I'm not sure what
he really needs to explain to anyone
honestly talking talking in rap bored
NFL Network joining me here Dan Patrick
show Andrew Luck his shoulder issue what
do we know about the his injury
yeah I was actually just on an
Indianapolis a couple days ago talking
to people about that I mean it you know
what's interesting is he is a starting
quarterback he's a very good one he's a
very highly paid one and he has not been
on the field for the first week or so of
training camp and you know the lack of
panic is tappable and they haven't gone
outside a quarterback from the outside
you know they have Scott tolsey not a
household name by a longshot and
luck is you know came out publicly and
said he's been throwing tennis balls and
they seem fine with this you know so I
think that's probably a good sign for
his progress and where he is the fact
that all those very smart people we know
how good he is you know how valuable it
is to the team have a very palpable lack
of freak out regarding his status that's
a good way to put it like a freak out oh
yeah and that's kind of what it is and
then you know in these situations
injuries a lot of times you sort of read
the tea leaves and figure out what
people are feeling and saying and how
they've reacted I talked to all of them
when I was in Indy and they seem to be
okay with things Ernest Lee boy let's go
Marshawn Lynch in the Oakland with the
Raiders you know the Raiders were threat
I think in the AFC before Derek Carr
went down now they bring in Marshawn
Lynch but what should the expectations
be for Marshawn Lynch being out of the
year on the NFL for a year then even but
year before that he wasn't exactly a
great running back at that time yeah
well he was injured but you know in with
most players I would say temper your
expectations coming back from you know
whether it's an injury or in this case
just an absence to spend a year being
Marshawn but he is not a normal dude and
you know the years I've spent covering
him and I've done a lot of time covering
Marshawn Lynch it is almost impossible
to compare him to anyone else so the
expectations I would say expect him to
be what he's been which is a very very
very good running back until I see him
otherwise that's what I'll expect do you
think the Jets are tanking
no no I think what the Jets did was make
a business decision of saying all right
if we are not going to compete for the
playoffs then why are we spending all
this money you know I don't think
tanking to me would be like our let's
see how that I don't think that's what
it is it's more just the realization
like why are we paying for instance you
know seven million dollars to a
thirtysomething receiver what he's not
going to be the one to help us get to
the playoffs and probably blocking the
progress of another receiver and like
why are we paying all that you know
David Harris - I mean a lot of money for
a middle linebacker who's a leader of a
team that doesn't seem to be going a lot
of places I mean I can I can certainly
understand the monetary decisions now
will it help them be worse probably but
I don't I don't think it's tanking
because you know the individual players
and the coaching staff are not on board
yeah but Ian how does it differentiate I
mean look I'm an NBA guy and the Sixers
did exactly this they stripped away
their veterans they were an average team
they tried to get a lot worse you know
players don't tank coaches don't tank
but management could tank and it sure
seems to me that this is a very Sixers
like blueprint that the Jets are
following yeah I mean I see what you're
saying and now you know and I'm not
trying to completely disagree with that
because if you want to say did they get
rid of a lot of their their high-profile
big-name players yeah they definitely
did you know I would also argue that you
know Nick Mangold is very good but you
know were they better with a 34 year old
Center making you know nine million
dollars a year you know I don't think
they were also the Sixers had a pretty
clear elaborate plan the process I
believe it's called oh yeah they're the
Jets are I'm not sure the Jets are
really there honestly always great to
visit with you and keep up the great
work man I appreciate the time all right
thanks for having me Betsy Ann Rapoport
NFL Network joining me here on the Dan
Patrick show the Dan Patrick show we
on audience